et la campagne pour la primaire se
poursuit à droite avec le déplacement
hier soir 2 françois fillon dans les
éviers l'ancien premier ministre de
nicolas sarkozy était à aubergenville où
il a une nouvelle fois reçu le soutien
de la maire de la commune également
sénatrice et secrétaire départemental
des républicains sofia prime à gérard
larcher président du sénat était lui
aussi présent pour appuyer cette
candidature de celui qui est
actuellement député de paris alors au
cours de son discours il a abordé la
question du terrorisme
françois fillon a également affirmé que
la france était en guerre et qu'il
allait renforcer les actions contre
l'état islamique dans le cadre d'une
coalition avec la russie notamment ou
encore l'iran il a également parlé
d'immigration et souhaité la mise en
place de quotas annuels
françois fillon qui aussi dans les
sondages entre la 3e et la 4e place loin
derrière alain juppé espère s'imposer
dans la dernière ligne droite
le scrutin de la primaire se déroule en
novembre prochain écoutez le pourquoi il
faut changer de président de la
république
pas seulement parce qu'il est de gauche
qu'on l'aiment pas et qu' on a envie
d'une alternance non il faut en changer
parce que son quinquennat est une
calamité son quinquennat est
caractérisée et vous savez que j'utilise
rarement des mots aussi violent il est
caractérisé par trois choses
l'imposture l'incompétence et le
mensonge